[Music]
Mike Tirico formerly the mothership
saw him last night and he was just
wandering around aimlessly didn't look
like we had any friends whatsoever and I
said Mike how do you dinner you were
aimless you were in and out that's true
I just came for the beer I I showed up
for the for the beer and then I left
they were honoring us Rich Eisen last
night absolutely and you were the MC
Hammer it was it was good Joe Buck busy
busy week Joe came he first won the Pat
Summerall award Kerry Summerall Pat's
wife was there Joe goes almost every one
of them it's really a nice honor but I
did see you yeah and what did I do when
I saw you we had very little interaction
other said other than you invited me to
the show what's that do for you got me a
beer thank you but you had nothing to do
you had no friends I was talking to like
15 people and you came in and I'm
introducing you to people have you
remember Mike Tirico used working spm
where did he go I should know he's here
works at NBC how did you introduce me
sub host of football man America right I
did I'm close
everywhere I go except when Dan's around
that I'm sub host Mike had a name nobody
had a name tag on that nine stop that
and I said his was hello my name used to
be Mike Tirico and I went wow aren't you
glad you came over nice morning oh yeah
could have gone to a couple more parties
I know I get that early so I'm going to
dance shows it's actually the first time
I'm seeing you guys in person but this
is my morning at home so in Michigan
home kids go to school I'm sitting there
in my office I'll make a cup of coffee
and I have you guys on my big screen I'm
doing my work around the house in the
morning this is like a normal Friday
morning for this is really good
how big was that moment when you decide
leave ESPN that you know let people in
along and build up to because everybody
says how could you leave ESPN it's scary
you know we're fortunately we had jobs
that we were walking into but it's still
leaving ESPN right yeah I think there
wasn't a moment because it was a few
months of thinking about it what am I
going to do and it really became an easy
decision know sometimes in guys I hate
to equate us to sports athletes but
those same free agents
he was no-brainer when I really weighed
all the options or a coaching decision
this was beyond the opportunity to work
with you every everything at NBC
although we did have a moment at the
Olympics great on the beat on the way
you in Rio you and I you know because
I've known Mike for 20 25 years 25 years
Jeff and we're coming out of commercial
break in like 15 seconds you know
15 14 coming back to you Mike and I went
can you believe that we're hosting the
ethanol appear at like exact I would and
I said and then it just kind of dawned
on us but how cool is that so cool
because I end for the radio listeners
this purpose shot on the TV show of us
working in Bristol together sitting next
to each other in these cubes that really
look like 80s office cubicles and we're
sitting back and we're writing the show
it's not a fake it's it's a real legit
moment and it's just incredible to think
about all the people when they see which
isin last night are you or everyone who
we work with so it wasn't one moment
there oh my gosh I'm leaving I think the
hardest part of leaving is right now
because I'm used to getting done with
football and on to Big Ten basketball
and NBA games and I worked a horse race
last week for NBC but I'm not gonna do
anything for another month or so till I
do some golf so my family is really
ready to get rid of me ha ha ha they
were so happy I was coming to see dad
don't you have a game like I'm wearing
everybody out at home I remember when I
left the mothership and I was home for
six months right
and I thought boy this can be great I
got home and the only person left at
home with my dog I'm sitting with the
damn dog in the front porch and I'm
going what the hell did I just do but
the dog is even saying what the hell did
you just do the kids are gone they're
off to school at 7:45 and go okay now
what oh the kids will be home accuses no
they're going to practice my son play
soccer my daughter plays basketball
they're off to practice okay everybody
be home any fun oh you guys okay if the
homework to do maybe want to talk to me
yeah no can you stay I don't know I've
got a husband okay I've been here for
you Dan
we'll take a break we'll continue with
my cure are you at the Super Bowl
working at all no I'm here for this
appearance in this we flew you in just
for this you didn't know that I did not
know this is in charge of the budget uh
I think paulius oh do you know I'm
coming to Temple with you guys - oh you
are nothing I do I'm the 58 for the next
time we would love to have you assemble
be absolutely welcome back with the Miss
Danette Mike Tirico right after his to
get the ultimate 4k HDR TV from Sony go
to amazon.com TV's on sale now purchase
any Sony 4k GOTV 95 $99 or up in an
additional $50 credit to Amazon use the
promo code paddy and we're back at the
Dan Patrick I've always wanted to do
that to someone so you you think you
could be add an ad for well we're Dan
for a day you could but what does it
entail for a week it's mean what do you
do all I all pretty guises call people
and then we relive his some adrenaline
the way people some say it's stalking
people but yes he's told to call people
and get them on the show we never see
what the guys are doing on their
computer screens I mean are they
tweeting Kellyanne Conway facts or what
are we doing whoa now we're talking
politics no no of it play nobody
watching CNN here or MSNBC or another
networks already going in a different
direction somebody wait yeah Mike what
are you doing having cue I just want to
know what the guys do all I do is sit
there I see four computer screens
McLovin do you want to tell Mike what
you do because we're actually oh I don't
know we're a lot closer to looking at
Kelly Rohrbach than Kelly Anne Conway
that is kind of seen it and we do mostly
yeah quite good this is impressive set
up the big picture of you yeah state of
Texas now see okay
this has come a long way because you
said this before do I smile too you said
this before it was risky to leave yeah
it was risky for you to leave yeah could
you left to something unknown if crying
I'm not not saying this because I'm your
friend or because we're on the air you
created something that was not happening
in
you took your own gig and made it into
something really big mm-hmm for other
people I wouldn't have done what you did
I had to go somewhere to know what I was
going to do so that's when the crowd
applauds right after that ask for the
crowd will pause thank you Mike would
you like a seat bottom on over Mike yeah
man here is uncomfortable you need to
keep all these colors when it comes to
Lucas seat back yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
they're not they're not first time with
a microphone oh we get mics Michael sit
on its back okay wake up where were we
I don't know but taking a voice to
Pebble yes I am and they haven't been
out to Pebble yet so I said it can
change your life so we're going out next
week for the Pebble Beach pro-am the
greatest place by the way Tiger
withdrawing I know I know what would it
surprise you more that he withdraws
makes the cut
plays misses the cut or actually has a
like a great finish so when he signed up
for these four tournaments in five weeks
I thought it would be good if he had won
top 15 a top 25 and made another cut
somewhere I didn't think he was going to
be top ten
we saw lead in the Bahamas but that was
a golf course that he plays a whole
bunch and 16 guys no cut it was a little
bit easier this now was back-to-back
weeks traveling and obviously you heard
he traveled commercial to this to this
event so we didn't have to do is break
up of the flights where you land because
of a private plane couldn't get there in
one long haul I was texting with Dan
Hicks Wednesday night when we were
watching on Golf Channel and just Tiger
just looked like he was injured like he
did last year or two years ago excuse me
oh he was playing it may be the end he
may not play again the question is how
do you how do you exit how do you
dismount from the top very uncomfortable
and very difficult well I don't know
he's not there to play and make cuts
he's there to win but he has to be now
Dan I know but the only way that this is
salvageable is if he understands the
restrictions and limitations he really
has and plays the game of golf
accordingly he thought they're trying to
swing it hard and you know he's lining
left and hitting it right and it just
there's such a disconnect there he's
trying to figure it out on the golf
course but physically can he do it can
he put in the hours
the Hogan's answer was it's always it's
in the dirt you keep practicing here to
find it he's tried to put as much time
as he can he's been patient didn't come
back early
but maybe look who's better at 41 than
they were in their 20s
especially when you have athletes who
are now bigger and stronger and hit it a
lot farther than Tiger does plus one
thing it's a swing back and his health
then there's the confidence of
contending so there are a lot of layers
to get back to saying he can come back
and do anything I feel bad for him
because I hate watching it go towards
the end like this I don't know if this
is the end this week hopefully over the
next few weeks he makes a cut here there
and starts to build something for
Florida yeah I didn't know what we were
going to expect and I said I'm not going
to learn anything the first couple of
tournaments that I would be surprised
right like I'm once we got to the end of
February I'd have a better assessment of
what I thought he was going to be able
to do but you have patience yeah I think
societally and media wise if you want
answers right this very second and this
is a patience project for sure he's Mike
Tirico from NBC great play-by-play voice
been with us for a year now what if Tom
Brady loses are we ready matter are we
ready for that
yep I guess so I mean it doesn't matter
what if Matt Ryan wins is it is it a
shocker
I think Atlanta in this unknown in this
era where we know everything about
everyone hey Lana might be a little bit
unknown to the football public they
weren't on Sunday oh there are a lot
unknown yeah they weren't on Sunday and
I don't even know if they were on a
Monday night this year I should know
that probably one but this is a team
that most people don't know a lot about
where we've had a lot of the repeat
customers Seattle a couple of times
obviously the New England in Denver
situations over the years so I'm excited
to see them on this big stage how are
their young defensive players Kiana Neal
the safety Vic Beasley the pass rushing
end are they going to grow in the
spotlight where they going to get on the
field and you've been on the field
before Super Bowls you know it's
different humming yeah they going to get
on the field and go oh my gosh next
Brady I've watched him play six Super
Bowls and I'm the seventh how are they
going to react to me that's the biggest
thing I want to see as the game plays
out but I feel like if the Patriots it
will be the Patriots lost not the
Falcons won because I think the media is
looking at what is a better story that
people are going to click on to or you
know embrace debate on it's going to be
a brave loss the big - the objet you
have a embrace debate more people watch
Big Ten basketball games big 12
basketball game in the middle of the
week then those conversation shows so
please that's a shot that's a no take
right there I like to repose it's great
it's great that people love all great -
these people are here great to your
shows here because it's constant
conversation about sports but we talk to
this I couldn't do what you guys do all
the time because I don't have a hot take
on everything because once I've gone out
and covered stuff I realized you don't
know until you've been out there and you
cover it you see it you don't know so I
can't sit here and talk about Dabo
Swinney and Clemson and then recruiting
because I haven't been there if you've
been there then at least to me you have
a clue about it so in any case to your
point a Tom Brady yes it'll become me
why didn't Tom Brady win is he finished
as a championship quarterback and all
that stuff but it's nonsense Atlanta's
offense is done amazing things against
some good defenses at times during the
year so I give him full credit yeah it's
their fun but I just think that we look
at Matt Ryan saying I'm waiting for him
to do in a big moment can Dan Quinn
match Bill Belichick really when it
comes down to people going to say can
Ryan match Brady right and Quinn match
Bill Belichick and Dan quizzes the third
time he's prepared a defense with a
Super Bowl in the last four years
because he did it with Seattle I know
Pete Carroll's got hands on it but Quinn
was involved and he's a guy who took a
year one team that couldn't get the
pieces to connect made them connecting
year two they're growing they're coming
I think it's great for the league that
Matt Ryan made the Super Bowl what do we
ask all the time is there a good
quarterback well here's one that we know
can take a team to the Super Bowl I
think it helps the whole league dove
somebody else out there as great against
39 it's amazing though what one win can
do for you oh yeah once you break into
that elite category I mean it it takes
the pressure off these court if Aaron
Rodgers didn't have one
different much different story yeah he'd
be hearing a whole lot about this look
at you you're Emmy award-winning TV
personality dan Patrick multiple times
yes I'm I'm just I'm just Mike Tirico
you don't have an Emmy no I won one with
Bob Leon outside the lines but I've
never won an Emmy so which is which is
fine but that's now your calling card
that's who you are
Paulie would you get one of Miami's in
the back hi take it off take it off the
third shelf that's why the first a
second show 25 years of friendship is
still valuable sometimes isn't it ladies
and gentlemen Mike Tirico the Dan
Patrick show weekday morning on audience
[Music]